joining us now and the damn paths show
Albert Bree over the Monday Morning
Quarterback and NBC Sports Boston Albert
thanks for joining us on short notice
today where do you think the NFL is
right now are they meeting are they
having discussions is there a statement
being prepared on the direction of the
roughing the passer penalty in the NFL
well I mean together the first problem
is that you're trying to analyze or
Terry's saying I just haven't covered
the Cowboys ten years ago serious
there's lots of things and you're going
to tie yourself in a press so if you're
trying to break down and line up every
single fair enough you know I III just
tell ya I think the NFL like and
especially I'd say over the last six or
seven years it's been a very rapid years
and you know they've been reactionary ii
think the huge part of what got them in
this mess in the first place you know is
that this rule the bodyweight rule was
put in as a reaction to a singular event
and that event of course was anthony bar
hit on on aaron rodgers last year and
you know unfortunately because they're
going kind of you know overboard can't
protect the quarterback they didn't
think of the consequences on the other
end and i'll tell you what I sent out
cut text so about a dozen defensive
coaches last night asked him like how do
you coach this how do you deal with this
and this you know I respond Sagat back
is you know it's just there are things
you can do to try and and coach guys to
tackle a certain way and take a
quarterback down a certain way but the
bottom line is is that you know they've
made the strike zone so small now that
you know the guys moving at that speed
into another person and aiming for an
area there are inevitably going to be
unavoidable unavoidable you know
situations where the momentum of the
defensive player is going to carry them
onto on top of the offensive player and
that's you know I in fact one of them I
asked one of these guys
defensive coordinator I asked well you
know what about the Clay Matthews hit
he's like I don't know how to coach that
out of someone you know this is an NFL
defensive coordinator and so you know I
don't know how much of the stuff that I
heard and this
sort of an informal polling last night
but I don't know how much of you know
what I heard last night from the D
mental coaches has gone up a five-fold
of League office you know but certainly
they've got a problem and now the
question becomes do they react to the
bad PR on a rule that was a reaction to
that PR or a reaction to a bad situation
you know that's the hard thing because
it's again like this is where the NFL's
gotten itself in trouble traditionally
in the past Albert is there a way to
walk back the rule without making an
announcement to sort of subtly
communicate to the officials hey just
cut it down by 25% how do they do that
well I mean if you if you look at the
rule the way it was written in its you
know they turned aunt Ann and in there
into or and like this is initially this
rule initially had been that you know it
was either and I don't have it in front
of me it was like an unnecessary
violence like you know going in a player
in unnecessarily violent way and landing
on top of the guy was all your body
weight and they subtly change the and to
or and that got lost and you know all
the hoopla over the helmet rule and I
don't know that any of us predicted it
was going to be a problem that it has
been I you know I would suggest going
back to the way it was you know I don't
know if they can do that it'd be
difficult of course the middle of the
season I can't think of much of a
president forward to change a rule back
like that you know but I I think one
thing they could do is they could tell
the officials like hey you know if a guy
if a guy picks up a guy in pile drives
done yeah you know sort of flag like
they're those things where you know when
you see it but if a guy is if the cons
if the contact is I mean fair and it
looks like the fact that the guy landed
with his body weight on top of the other
player was incidental then make a
judgment call and let some of that stuff
folks I don't think anybody and I don't
think the league when they when they
when they made the rule or it is now I
don't think the league intended for you
know hits like the two Clay Matthews
hits over the last couple of weeks to
the stuff that was going to
call Albert why do you think there isn't
a current active NFL player on the
competition committee to see in real
time what how the players would react to
rules and get a person who's currently
playing instead of a guy who's been
retired for ten years I've never thought
about that that's a great idea it's a
really good yeah you know I if I do this
part of the problem with the league in
general is that they you know and this
is I mean god we could we talk for three
hours of this let's do it the
relationship the relationship between
the league and the players has been
fractured for a long time and this is
the way that you've operated and it's
unfortunate you know but and this is a
little stuff that really ticks the
players off you know and I you can line
it up with the anthem issue you know the
fact that no one in that room in May
thought when they were putting a new
anthem rule and that hey we should call
the Union or hey maybe we should have
invited a half dozen players to sit in
here in the room with us the fact that
they didn't think of that
like tells you everything you need to
know about why the league's relationship
with the players is where it is and and
and that's another one of these that
this would be another one of those you
know where it's like it's like what you
just said I hadn't even thought of it
and the reason I hadn't even thought of
it is that's not the way the leagues
operate right you know it was such an
easy common-sense thing to put a couple
and he maybe put two offensive players
and two defensive players you know in
the room with them when they're doing
the meetings in February or at the
combine with them are the owners games
with them makes all the sense in the
world
it's just that the relationship between
the players and we and the players and
the owners hasn't been there really you
know anytime recently and I think not
only you know like not only that would
that help in a situation like this one I
think it would also probably help from a
global standpoint to make the players
feel a little bit more like partners
which i think would go a long way to
repair the relationship albert Breer the
Monday Morning Quarterback and NBC
Sports Boston joining us on the Dan
Patrick show moving down to Tampa what
are the long-term ramifications we know
short term to Dirk Qatar wants to win
games and will probably go with Ryan
Fitzpatrick as starting quarterback but
if they stick with Fitzpatrick for the
foreseeable future what is the money
issue the signing issue to keep Jameson
found that Timor jettison him and move
on from him well I mean they don't
really have honestly like there's not
much logistically that would prevent
them from moving on after this year
outside of injury like if he's hurt and
he can't pass his physical and March no
that was the risk in picking up his
option you know and so you know that's
if he's injured you know then you know
you're on the hook for the 20 million if
he's healthy he gets to the end of the
season healthy and then you don't need
to do anything you know and so I
actually don't think that this is and
look no one's gonna say the turf-cutter
and Jason life all those got those jobs
are on the line no one's gonna say it's
right so I mean III actually looked at
this is it look at that as sort of a 1/2
way positive develop for them and here's
what I mean there are three outcomes
here as long as you stick with it it's
one you ride the hot hand and you know
in fits brings you to the playoffs so
that's number one that's a positive
development that saves everybody's job
to Jameis gets you know you know Jameis
is really motivated behind Fitz does all
the right things and you know then Fitz
you know it takes a wrong turn in
November and you got to go to Jameis and
you're getting the very best out of
Jameis what that points playing for his
career and maybe that saves your jobs
and then the third one what is you know
that Jameis doesn't take this as
seriously as he should and Fitz doesn't
play well and then Jameis comes in and
he doesn't play well either and everyone
gets fired which I think would have been
the case anyway if Jameis didn't play
well this year you know and at least
then the organization has a answer on
Jameis and if that the answer is that
that he's just not very good for years
then everyone was getting fired anyway
because that's what happens when you
draft a guy number one overall and you
strike out on them so like I actually
look at this and I say to myself in a
weird way you know you can lay out three
conclusions and you know those three
conclusions you
logically say well you know the one bad
one you know is inevitable anyone who
can strike out on a quarterback that
high in the draft and the other two
might save the guy's job our final two
minutes I got one topic I want to ask
you about is the Earl Thomas situation
the pro-bowl safety out in Seattle he's
basically wagging the dog out there that
he knows that they need him for any
chance to have a decent defense and he's
gonna practice when he wants can you see
this but being a watershed moment where
players use every move they have to
negotiate with the team Le'Veon Bell
says I'm just not gonna play Earl Thomas
says I'll practice when I want and play
because I know you need me are they like
changing the direction of negotiations
in the league it's I mean I I don't
think so because I just there aren't
very many players who have the capital
to do this sort of thing and levy on
Bell made 12 million dollars last year
I'm grant he wasn't a first-round pick
he's a second round taken so the money
he made his first wasn't great but he
does have some money in the bank Earl
Thomas you know the first-round pick and
then signed the top of the market sector
contracts so he's got the money to pull
off something like this it's a lot
harder if you're a guy on the roster guy
who's you know looking to get the second
contract and David Johnson I think will
be a good example of it you know play
Todd Gurley tiger always in the same
draft closet David Johnson Todd Gurley
could legitimately threatened to hold
out because he's made a lot of money
already and so you know the Rams move on
him and get the deal done one piece of
leverage the Cardinals had over David
Johnson was I mean they pretty much knew
because he was a fourth-round take
they're not gonna David Johnson is gonna
be sitting out anything like David
Johnson isn't going isn't going to walk
away from the money we're paying him
because he hasn't made that much already
that's the way the Matt vast majority
players at the position that the vast
majority players are in and so you know
could it affect top of the market
negotiations with guys who have already
made money
I mean sure sure it could if it works
for parole Thomas or it works for
Le'Veon Bell you know sure I could see
some certain other players following
suit even though the cost is really
really high you need to do something
like that under the current CBA rules
the thing is that guys are in that
position that representative
small percentage of leagues I don't know
it's really gonna have some some sort of
widespread effect on the rank-and-file
NFL player Alber final 30 seconds you
cover the Patriots as much as any
reported in NFL which would you bet on
if you had to make a bet on one of these
two extremes
the Patriots missed the playoffs or the
Patriots win the Superbowl you can only
pick one I've seen this movie before
this is you know I a lot of really bad
signs through three weeks and not not
the least of which is that opening day
win which looks great right when when
they went on September 9th now doesn't
what the same because Houston's on three
you know and so I doesn't look like
there's a ton around Brady right now now
look at Edelman back and you know they
hope they can get something out of Josh
Gordon and I'll change everything but
that even still looks old and slow the
awesome still has holes and you know you
have to wonder if some of the bad
history from last year starts through
its head if things kind of continue down
the path they're going good I mean if I
had to put my money on it I mean I don't
know how anybody could say they won't
it's hard to see a way for them to
figure it out because they figured it
out so many times in the past and I
think it's sort of a fool's bet to go
against spell check and break free or
the Monday Morning Quarterback NBC
Sports thanks for joining us on the Dan
Patrick show for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]